und jetzt ist auch mir wieder frau
professor falk zugeschaltet schön dass
sie auch noch bei uns den vorfall vielen
dank ich habe es jetzt auch gehört was
für änderungen da also in kraft treten
sollen ganz essenziell wird ja jetzt
auch beispielsweise die inzidenz
ausgetauscht gegen einen anderen wert
also die hospitalisierung rate damit
wird das ganze also enger ein bisschen
enger auch an das aktuelle
gesundheitssystem geknüpft wie wichtig
war dass wir wie wichtig finden sie
diese maßnahme
diese maßnahme ist auf jeden fall
wichtig weil es wurde ja schon gesagt
die
fallzahlen sind manchmal ja auch sehr
schwer nachzuvollziehen gerade weil sie
regional sehr unterschiedlich sind und
ich glaube das signal war generell dass
ihr einheitliche rahmenbedingungen in
deutschland brauchen so habe ich das
signal wahrgenommen und das ist auch
tatsächlich so ich kenne die
niedersächsischer seite sehr gut in der
wir über die korona verordnung
informiert werden und in niedersachsen
ist das schon so da haben sie
verschiedene auflistungen und in der
niedersächsischen auf der
niedersächsischen seite ist schon in den
letzten wochen die hospitalisierung rate
angegeben und wenn man darauf geht dann
waren die warnstufen andere und die
werden jetzt vereinheitlicht und es ist
jetzt natürlich eine ganz sinnvolle
schritt dass man auch als bürgerinnen
und bürger sich informieren kann wie
sieht die hospitalisierung rate aus in
den jeweiligen bundesländern das wird
man vielleicht noch regional auch noch
aufschlüsseln können und dann kann man
sehen dass niedersachsen diese drei jahr
zwischen die sie erst den ersten schritt
zwischen drei und sechs
hospitalisierungen pro woche pro 100000
einwohner schon überschritten hat das
ist im moment 4,7 und da kann man glaube
ich sehr transparent dann auch
nachvollziehen wann welche maßnahmen
gelten ich denke das ist ein sehr
sinnvolles eine sehr sinnvolle maßnahme
das so auf den weg zu bringen
ich wollte dass euch auch jetzt hier
eigentlich gerade gerne zeigen auf
meinem bildschirm das können wir auch
mal versuchen nämlich diese das ist
nicht so einfach das rutsch mir die
ganze zeit weg gibt mir in kurzen moment
dass ich das hier für euch gut
einrichten kann also hier oben sehen wir
nach wie vor beim rk ii die sieben tage
incidents haben jetzt aber gehört dass
das ja jetzt nicht mehr von von viel
wert ist wenn es darum geht neue regeln
zu beschließen und jetzt suche ich mich
hier durch und dann habe ich gefunden
also hier ist die sieben tage incidents
nach hospitalisierung jetzt muss man nur
aber auch sagen also aktuell stand jetzt
noch wenn man da auf der seite unterwegs
ist ist das also der zeitraum für einen
monat den ich mir hier angucken kann und
aufgeschlüsselt nach einzelnen
bundesländern sehe ich das jetzt auch
nicht also das ist vielleicht auch was
das ist jetzt noch nicht ad hoc so ganz
klar ersichtlich oder frau falk frau
professor falk wie das sich genau
feststellen lässt vielleicht für jede
region oder ja ich hab das schon mal ein
bisschen gerade nebenbei versucht
herauszufinden für verschiedene
bundesländer niedersachsen hat es
tatsächlich und da sieht man schon die
letzten wochen wie sich dieser wert
leider langsam nach oben bewegt hat
andere bundesländer haben einfach andere
darstellungsformen ich glaube da sind
einfach die länder wirklich jetzt
gefordert auf ihren seit webseiten wo
sie die korona verordnungen haben das
dann genau transparent und leicht
verständlich auf zufügen aufzuführen
diese seite in niedersachsen ist ja gut
kenne ich schon lange guckt da immer
wieder drauf und da sieht man es
wirklich und kann dann auch sehen ob wir
kommen an diese grenzwerte heran und es
gibt die zahlen die müssen jetzt nur von
den ländern entsprechend aufbereitet
werden und dann auch so auf den
webseiten kommuniziert werden und srk
hat ja aufgabe bundesweit
zusammenzufassen und es gibt werte die
sind dann nach zum teil nicht nur
bundesländern sondern sogar landkreisen
aufgeschlüsselt da hatten wir bis jetzt
eben die fallzahlen das gibt es immer
eine excel-tabelle die wird mit
sicherheit jetzt ergänzt durch diese
excel-tabelle die nach landkreisen oder
zumindest bundesländern diese
hospitalisierung sinti grenzen hat das
ist natürlich schon wichtig weil man
daran einfach sieht dass wir an einen
punkt gekommen sind wo unsere
krankenhaus kapazitäten wirklich extrem
belastet sind und ein punkt der ist
gerade so ein bisschen untergegangen der
ist mir total wichtig es war nämlich
auch die bundeskanzlerin hat es gesagt
das ist eine einen bonus für die pflege
gerade auch die intensivpflege geben
sollte ich glaube das ist ein ganz
wichtiges signal denn diese menschen
leisten so viel seit fast zwei jahren
und es war mehr als notwendig und jetzt
wäre es gut wenn es nicht nur bei worten
gebe sondern auch taten folgen und zwar
schnell
gleichzeitig hatten im vorfeld auch
immer wieder hat noch immer wieder
berufsverbände davor gewarnt dass aber
auch zu machen also die impfpflicht in
jetzt krankenhaus und für pflegeberufe
weil es da schon auch befürchtungen gab
dass das natürlich noch mehr menschen
abschrecken könnte in diesem beruf zu
arbeiten
da sind wir jetzt gespannt was passiert
ja
ich hab gerade von dem bonus gesprochen
ja genau natürlich absolut selten ganz
wichtig hier diese pflicht da hat herr
müller einmal kurz das noch mal diesen
wichtigen begriff erwähnt einrichtungs
bezogen dann wie sie richtig sagen es
wäre auch kein gutes signal jetzt
ausgerechnet wieder die pflegekräfte
sozusagen da ein besonders in die
pflicht zu nehmen die sowieso schon sehr
viel leisten in den krankenhäusern ist
es sowieso schon so dass da ein sehr
hoher anteil der pflegekräfte wirklich
geimpft ist und die muss man da wirklich
auch mal einen schutz nehmen das sind
nicht die menschen die da jetzt noch
irgendwie zur disposition stehen sondern
die einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
die diskutiert wird ist ja etwas das
eben nicht nur das direkte personal in
der pflege sondern wirklich auch vor
allem die mobilen alten und
pflegeeinrichtungen in mitte dahin
einnimmt und eben nicht berufsbezogen
ist so hab ich zumindest verstanden das
würde man auch nach allem was die
medizinerinnen und mediziner sagen er
einrichtungs bezogen machen wie es noch
ganz wichtig die umsetzung das hat herr
zimmermann ja gerade gesagt ist
natürlich ein gesetztes vorgang derzeit
braucht was wir jetzt aber brauchen ist
handeln da wir es ja eine möglichkeit
die auskunftspflicht zu ermöglichen so
dass arbeitgeber wissen wer es geimpft
und wer nicht so dass man ohne dass man
jetzt gesetzes dinge zur hand hat den
arbeitsalltag vielleicht so strukturiert
dass man für die wohl in gruppen die das
risiko dass da menschen sind die nicht
geimpft sind einfach reduziert indem man
den arbeitsalltag etwas umstrukturiert
das wäre glaube ich eine pragmatische
herangehensweise ohne dass man nämlich
jetzt wartet bis diese gesetzes
geschichten da auf den weg gebracht sind
und das signal ist glaube ich auch ganz
wichtig dass das kommt bewirkt ja auch
schon einen handeln bei den menschen das
haben wir aus der cosmo studie von
cornelia betsch aus erfurt gelernt die
ja immer sehr gut verfolgt wie reagieren
menschen auf die situation und die hat
eindeutig gezeigt dass ankündigungen
auch schon einen moment um generieren so
dass menschen sich danach richten und
danach und ich glaube das war heute ein
sehr gutes signal in die richtung in
drei wochen am 9 dezember soll wieder
evaluiert werden wir wohl stehen mir
dann wie geht es dann weiter frau
professor falk wenn in drei wochen erst
evaluiert wird und geschaut wird was hat
es gebracht sie haben es angesprochen
zeit haben wir eigentlich wenig also wo
stehen wir in drei wochen
das hängt davon ab wie die menschen die
sich heute mit den nachrichten
beschäftigen darauf reagieren und als
ein geborener optimist würde ich immer
das mitnehmen was eben aus der cosmo
studien heraus kommt diese ankündigungen
die sind die werden schon von den
menschen wahrgenommen ob das jetzt
regelungen sind die den arbeitsplatz
betreffen ob das regelungen sind wie man
sich mit 2g und 3g noch wo kann man
hingehen wie wird das organisiert es
werden kontrollen angekündigt allein das
ist glaube ich ein signal in die breite
der bevölkerung dass die situation nicht
nur ernst ist sondern dass sie auch ein
handeln erfordert und ich denke dass
oder meine hoffnung ist dass die
menschen begreifen dass sie auch schon
handeln können nämlich sich selbst
testen sich zu überlegen dass man
möglichst die impf angebote wahrnimmt
dass man die booster angebote wahrnimmt
die dritte impfung dass das handeln
jetzt schon einsetzt
vorausschauend weil man merkt wir sind
jetzt gefordert die politik braucht
immer zeit so dass das handeln jetzt
schon einsetzt und dass wir dann doch
etwas erreichen bis zu dieser nächsten
evaluation im neuen dezember solon ist
es ja nicht mehr hin aber das wäre ein
bisschen die hoffnung dass die menschen
wirklich gemerkt habe um jeder hat kann
etwas dazu beitragen wirklich jeder und
jede und dass man das dann auch wirklich
versucht zu vermitteln dass man handeln
kann bevor der gesetzgeber irgend etwas
vorgibt und ich glaube das signal kamen
und zumindest habe ich das so
wahrgenommen schon auch heute rüber sagt
professor christine folgt die
präsidentin der deutschen gesellschaft
für immunologie vielen dank dass sie für
uns vor und nach dieser sendung
bereitgestanden haben und eingeordnet
haben sehr gerne